I have to say though that like maybe
I've just been sort of I'm with an
Australian man so yeah and it's a
different culture and like we're growing
our own vegetables and farm-to-table
farm-to-table and I'm not so with my
pulse on what's happening in the world
you're not just dating an Australian guy
right I mean I'm married
oh yeah married to a restaurant guy just
an Austrian he is what's his name his
name is Curtis Stone yeah and what does
he do love him a chef yeah and and it's
TV host I guess yeah yeah and he owns
Glen's Gwen which is a restaurant in
Hollywood and then one in Beverly Hills
he's a so he's a celebrity world famous
chef he's mmm above he's the one that's
above the you know like we're here yeah
and he's up there with his like fans
yeah I give the illusion of fanciness
but I'm not I don't think yeah and
whenever I see him you give him very
long ride don't know but dude I do right
yeah you do because he is um he's an
Adonis yes no but you don't when you see
him though he is like Paul was a thick
he seems like he's a sick dish is a
thick dick well just I've never seen it
but through the pants I'm not gay I just
what I mean you buddy straight up just
telling me that you've looked fair
that's his eye level yeah and I but also
he is just a seems like he's a gentle
nice guy yeah and when we you we were
blessed to went we ate at gwen that one
night that was the funniest thing i
think the first thing he said to bobby
was oh that's you i think we share a
wife and then you recoiled like a
there's just something about him that
like kind of excites me and also scared
yeah same way
he actually was he doesn't cook there he
doesn't he's he's not back there he is
the owner of the because our meal he
goes most nights to be honest like you
know I'm Janna he loves it he's kind of
a control freak too but like he's there
Wow and then you have to just kids are
like supermodels they're so cute they're
the best they're so much fun right
complete like it's just though they're
weird and wonderful and it's awful and
wonderful to watch like your personality
come out and two other brand-new human
beings are oh but they're like did they
seem like I've only seen them through
videos I've never met them but they seem
funny and outgoing and confident they
are cool kids I have to say like I don't
I before I became a mom I did I did not
like it when people were always like oh
my kids and they're all so special and I
think it's it's it's important when you
become a parent to have your own
autonomy apart from being just a parent
well I am obsessed as you would be with
you know your own kids and they're
they're amazing they're funny and
because of you me uh-huh I'm Hudson my
six-year-old wants to be a stand-up
comic and it's like a real thing it is
trying out Joe Uncle Bob oh my god we'll
tour together
I'll show them everything I saw
everything about comedy came out weird
everyone but everyone listening now
everyone let's see now that's not me
i'm a i-i-i-i I support dreams and I
want people to grow yeah but not that
uncle mentor Uncle Bob mentor boy yeah
yeah yeah yeah he'd like that to he's
he's really into it yeah not he's not
like funny in his stand-up persona but
he's funny in real life yeah yeah he is
to get him to be himself on stage and
then that's why it takes a long time but
when he's 18
but you know you'll open for me yeah
they'll be great yeah he's got a little
bit of a stir the streak of that look he
likes the attention of it are you
hesitant of your kids doing show
business you know like yeah for sure I
think I'm I started when I was really
little it was just a big like accident I
saw that Toys R Us commercial yeah you
thought it was so cute was Oracle so
Arkell Jenny Lewis from yeah I look
hella Kylie yeah yes do you did you ever
watch the lair of the Larry Sanders Show
yeah Scotney miss Oh more like you know
but my mom and dad were not in the
business they're just like average
Pasadena California folk and I was in a
ballet school and somebody came to the
ballet school to take pictures and the
kid the parents signed off on you know
letting these pictures go to a camera
company and I don't remember this story
my mom tells it to me in a like really
disjointed way apparently somebody saw
the photo and then asked my mom if I
could be in this ad and it turned out to
be like in Time magazine it was like
this beautiful black-and-white photo of
little girls in a ballet class and then
an agent called the ballet school and it
just kind of all happened and I'm like
mom who had to look at a Thomas guide
and get me to audition it was like what
is happening I don't want this to happen
and I just never stopped working since I
was five Wow like it's bizarre and I
like being an actor but it was kind of a
weird thing for a kid to do
[Music]